sir
right right
man why don't you go in there what
everybody was scared out of their way
everyone okay uh I have an announcement
apparently in business school they don't
teach you how to operate a toaster oven
because some smart sexy temp left his
cheese Peta an oven instead of timing it
for the toaster thing
[Laughter]
wow okay well I guess they don't teach
how to operate a toaster oven in
business that's exactly what I said hey
did you miss that thing there Ryan were
you absent toast oven 101. you failed
I'm so sorry
hey I know what will impress everybody
I'll start a fire
oh man bad idea bad idea jeans I have
its song attention everyone that I want
to sing that I wrote especially for this
occasion when I was up there among the
flames
ready Ryan started the fire it was
always burning since the world returning
Ryan started the fire it was always fun
everybody
I can't believe I started the fire
let's go
come on hurry up you guys
oh my life Michael what's wrong
everything's wrong
the stress of my modern office has
caused me to go into a depression
depression isn't that just a fancy word
for feeling bummed out Dwight you
ignorant [__] depression is a very
serious illness over 32 000 people
commit suicide every year according to a
2004 study is that the last year the
data was available yes my head is in
such pain and turmoil
don't do anything rash wait where's the
warehouse guys
I didn't
I didn't think you needed him for this
part okay that's you said to just that's
the whole point dummy okay I'm on it
okay
attention blue collar workers
what are the odds that this is in any
way real
I'd say like ten thousand to one okay
I'd like 10 bucks on those odds
if someone gives you ten thousand to one
on anything you take it
if John Mellencamp ever wins an Oscar
I am going to be a very rich dude
Michael is up on the roof and he's
acting strange oh my life Michael what's
wrong everything is wrong Dwight the
stress of my modern office has made me
depressed depressed isn't that just a
fancy word for feeling bummed out Dwight
you ignorant [__] well you know the
first performance was a little off but I
really think they hit their stride in
the second show
um might even bring my parents tomorrow
to the matinee and that is why I am
going
excuse my favorite person seated
what was that pay no attention to the
spirits that haunt this Hallowed Ground
is that your cousin most
yes Moe's is my cousin and he lives here
he will always be my best friend
unless things go well with Ryan today in
which case I won't hang out with Moe's
so much anymore what is the greatest
danger facing Dunder Mifflin Outsourcing
and consolidation of competition wrong
flash floods what is the true cause of
Robert mifflin's suicide
depression wrong he hated himself final
question young Ryan Howard
what
is Michael Scott's
greatest fear
um loneliness
maybe women wrong
he's not afraid of anything
also I would have accepted snakes
fear is what it's all about you cannot
sell while undergoing fear you need to
Vanquish fear one must wrestle fear to
the ground you will now wrestle my
cousin more no okay all right all right
you're a freak I'm not doing this
anymore
Ryan you don't have to wrestling Ryan
get in the coffee
Ryan
bye Ryan
you see nice
we're all animals
hear me Billy you don't look so good
what's got you down I got problems Billy
big problems you got problems my TV
don't work
I paid 30 bucks a month for the damn
satellite what so who's it can't even
get the damn game man you tell me what's
worse than that
don't ever change Billy
Billy golden face is going to blow up
the NHL All-Star game tomorrow
see what you mean about problems I know
it'll cheer you up
that table of bachelorettes over there
bought you this drink
hey ever banged an entire bachelorette
party baby
why are you singling my line out like a
million years later
I'm too depressed to save the big game
Billy I'm gonna cheer you up the only
ways I know house hey kid
hit G9 on the jukebox no Billy I haven't
done that dance since my wife died
there's a whole crowd of people out
there who need to learn how to do the
scar
foreign
[Music]
in a major way
you jump to the right and you shake your
hand and you jump to the left and you
shake that hand you meet new friends you
tie some yawn and that's how you do this
gone you jump to the right and you shake
that hand and you jump to the left and
you shake that hand meet new friends tie
that yard that's how you do this gone
you jump to the right and you shake your
hand
meet new friends tie that yarn that's
how you do this is doing the scar in his
day then I'm the biggest Queer on Earth
all right
Michael I'm sorry I'm really really
sorry I think I was just relieved to see
that Michael's gone got his confidence
back yeah Michael the movie's amazing
it's like one of the best movies I've
ever seen in my life you should enter it
in festivals or carnivals
thoughts pretty good reaction it's
pretty cool right
did you like it did you like that
which part
all right
no it's not good enough it's not good
enough some people are really popping on
screen hey
did you pick a new chair it's been a
while Pam when I first opened this
catalog
I thought I was just going to be picking
out a chair but instead you found
something to distract you from ever
picking out a chair Michael started the
process of selecting a new chair about
three weeks ago and normally I wouldn't
care but he promised me his old one it's
way better
it's one of these
I really want it
have you ever seen this woman
her the one in the really great mesh
black high back swivel chair
so eyes look at her eyes she's got I
don't know what it is exactly she
dresses like a professional and yet you
know there is a side of her that could
just curl up on a couch or in a great
chair oh yeah maybe but
remember after my dinner party when I
said that I was swearing off women
now you remember your dinner party I
think what I meant was that I am
completely swearing off one woman
I think that fate put this catalog in my
head actually I put the catalog in your
hand because you have to pick out a new
chair what is it like being single I
like it I like
starting each day with a sense of
possibility
and I'm optimistic because every day I
get a little more desperate
and desperate situations results